The other day I was exploring options for a
go-wide beatdown deck, so naturally I was on
the EDHRec pages of Toski and Tovolar. And on
those pages, I found something that bothered
me. On both pages, 60% of decks run Cultivate.
Now, obviously EDHRec has some inherent flaws
that get further compounded through usage of the
website; it’d be cool if somebody made a video
about that or something, but still. 60%. With
a commander that’s low-mana enough not to be
boosted out by the ramp part and who draws enough
cards to not need the tacked on land-to-hand.
You could spend that three mana on literally
anything else. There’s also some questionable
draw run in these decks whose commander is an
insanely powerful draw spell. So, what gives?
Well, I think this ties into a culture of hailing
certain cards as must-plays, one that exists both
online and in IRL circles. This sort of effect
has likely always been somewhat the case among
various circles in Magic: the Gathering, since
it’s a social game with an established community,
but EDH is especially vulnerable to cycles
of over-hype about particular cards. This
is because it’s an even more social format
than the baseline due to having four players,
and also, the fact that it’s singleton and
100 cards means that there’s kind of a lot
of room for fluff in decks and it’ll take
longer for players to identify a mediocre
card than it would in a 60 card format. There
will be the cards that truly should be added
to most decks on the basis of power—Sol Ring,
Counterspell, Mystic Remora—and you can go check
out my budget cards video if you want my saucy,
saucy opinions about them. But there will also
be cards regarded in the same lens but which
truly don’t belong in all or even most decks,
and I want to focus on a specific category
of cards among these: mana ramp spells.
First, a quick overview. Ramp
makes your amount of mana go up,
typically permanently barring interaction
from your opponents. It’s nigh-ubiquitous
in EDH due to the slow speed of the
format, with the first and second
most played nonland cards in the format both
being ramp spells. And don’t get me wrong,
ramp is fantastic and there are lots of great
ramp spells out there. But as you can probably
guess by the first couple minutes of this video,
I have opinions about some of them. Specifically,
I think people gravitate toward certain ones
that are considered “staples”, even when there
are other options that are much better suited to
their deck. So, treat this video as a guide—how
to stop jamming Cultivate into every deck, and
figure out what your deck actually wants instead.
Hopefully there’s plenty of nuance to be gleaned
here, but this is a video principally stemming
from me getting upsetti spaghetti about
Cultivate, so let’s talk about that first.
Cultivate, along with its twin Kodama’s Reach, is
a Rampant Growth that costs an extra mana and has
a Lay of the Land attached. It’s a straightforward
formula with some clear appeal in a slow format,
and evidently Wizards agreed in 2011—it’s
in all three green precons in the first
EDH set. This alone likely contributed
to the card’s popularity, and honestly,
the card is right at home in these decks—three
color decks with questionable manabases and a
healthy spattering of 7-9 mana cards. When you
play Cultivate, you’re actively choosing an extra
land to hand rather than the speed of a two mana
ramp spell, and this is absolutely a tradeoff that
some decks want. The more colors you play, the
more that extra land will matter, and colorfixing
might be a valuable goal in its own right if
you’re running a lot of colors with not a lot
of budget. If you’re playing five color and you
have any three colors that include green, a turn
three Cultivate sets you up for a turn 4 with a
mana of each color available—that’s a great deal!
This usefulness as a setup piece is most obvious
in a five color deck, but the same logic also
works in a deck with fewer colors—as a general
principle Cultivate is best geared toward decks
looking for a pivotal 5 or 6 mana turn. This
brings me to a major consideration when picking
out ramp—mana curve. A lot of decks will have one
or more major mana value numbers they care about,
and your ramp package should be formulated to
fit this. My Glissa deck wants to play Glissa
on turn 2 whenever possible followed up with
more ramp spells, so if we look at a graph of
the mana value of the deck’s ramp spells, it’s
big spikes on 1 and 4 mana, and a smaller spike
on 7 because the deck is a disgusting greed
pile. There are only a few two and three cost
ramp spells since the deck prefers to skip 2
mana and play Glissa on 3 mana, and the ramp
spells of these costs that are in the deck either
create untapped lands or have flexible mana costs.
When you’re adding a ramp spell to a deck, you
should be asking “what is this ramping toward?”
Wanting more lands in general isn’t necessarily
the wrong answer, but if the most important
mana value you’re pushing toward is four, you
shouldn’t run a bunch of three mana ramp spells.
This is part of what prompts my eyebrow raising
when I see 60% of Toski decks running the card.
It doesn’t ramp into the commander, it takes up a
mana slot that could have gone to a card-drawing
beater, and the commander itself encourages volume
of creatures rather than size. This means you
probably don’t want that many cards on 5 or 6 mana
other than, I dunno, Mr. Squirrels. The commander
also draws you a ton of cards, and if your deck
has 33 forests, each of those draws has a healthy
one third chance of getting you the exact land
you want. You’re playing a mono-colored deck,
and if you play Cultivate you’re effectively
overpaying for ramp that gives you an upside
you don’t need. I find Cultivate questionable in
Tovolar for similar reasons—two colors is still
few enough that the color fixing probably isn’t
necessary, and werewolves top end consists of,
like, a handful of 5 and 6 drops? Rampant
Growth is almost certainly better but I’m
not sure I’d even go for that over a two
drop beater that can draw you some cards.
Card type is another consideration with regard
to ramp, since artifacts and especially creatures
will die to removal and board wipes, but land
destruction is much less common. However,
dorks and rocks are often more efficiently
costed than cards that grab lands,
so there are tradeoffs to be had. They all
have their place, but the places tend to be
different. Obviously, for non-green decks, bless
their hearts, you’re mostly stuck with rocks,
but that doesn’t necessarily mean green decks
will never want rocks. Single green dorks tend
to be the most mana-efficient ramp option
at lower budgets, so I tend to go for them
in any deck where the 3 cmc slot is important
but the 2 cmc slot is unimportant. My Glissa
deck and my Meria deck both have three mana
commanders that they try to land on curve,
but Glissa runs dorks because it has very few
2 mana plays and Meria runs rocks because the 1
and 2 mana slots are very important for the deck.
In a third one of my green decks, Scapeshift is
a key piece of the deck, so the deck runs mostly
land-grabbing spells in its ramp suite even though
they’re slower than single green dorks. Long story
short, different decks will want different things,
and these are just a handful of examples
of what I ended up on with my green decks.
A final consideration when considering ramp
cards is the net mana cost vs the upfront
mana cost. For something like Rampant Growth or
Cultivate, these values are identical since they
don’t immediately offer more mana, but some
spells give you untapped lands. For example,
Skyshroud Claim has an upfront cost of 4, but
a net cost of 2 if you grab Forests that enter
untapped. Two ramp spells I generally prefer
to Cultivate in 2 color decks are Harrow and
Grow from the Ashes, as they grab untapped lands
and thereby allow for more flexible turns than a
card that grabs tapped lands. If we look at mana
rocks, most theoretically offer mana immediately,
but in practice that can differ by when they’re
played and what deck is playing them. Signets can
be a net mana cost of 1 after turn 2 if the
symbols line up, but on 2 mana they can’t do
much else. Similarly, colorless-tapping rocks
like Mind Stone add mana immediately if you
have a place to put one colorless mana, but if
you don’t they’re just the sticker mana cost.
I like to think I’ve offered a little toolbox
here in picking out the most appropriate ramp,
and as a final point I’ll address an important
question that I’ve been skirting around so
far—that being how much ramp a deck should
run. This question honestly depends on so
many factors that I’d feel irresponsible offering
a straightforward answer or even a framework. The
best way to tell the right amount of your deck
is, well, to play it and see if it feels like it
has the right amount of ramp. If you’re ramping
to a particular value, does the deck succeed at
that consistently? Does it do so too well, eating
up deck space and leaving you with awkward spare
mana on a lot of turns? There are also differences
in the size of mana ramp spell, so if you find
yourself drawing too many ramp spells but want
the same ramping capability, you can cut some
small ones for a bigger one or two. Conversely,
you can do the opposite maneuver if your opening
hands seem consistently loaded with expensive
ramp spells you can’t get to quickly enough.
There may very well be strong ramp spells—Elvish
Mystic, Nature’s Lore, Thought Vessel—that don’t
end up being quite what your deck wants, and this
is okay. The best ramp solution isn’t gonna be
one size fits all. At the end of the day, what I’m
trying to say here is simply that you should look
at your deck’s ramp suite critically. I think when
it comes to the traditionally simpler parts of an
EDH deck—the lands, the removal, the ramp—a lot
of people have the idea that they can kinda gloss
over these things and focus their efforts on the
juicy synergies that comprise the spiritual core
of the deck. But these parts are what lets
the core of the deck do its thing smoothly,
so taking a critical eye toward them will
likely improve your deck more than you think.